well the US House of Representatives has
passed a bill to impose sanctions on
Chinese officials for the country's
treatment of Uighur Muslims now more
than a million Weaver's and other Muslim
minorities are kept in what Beijing
calls reeducation camps now the bill
aims to end the quote arbitrary
detention torture and harassment of this
Muslim minority community China's
foreign ministry has criticized the bill
as a smear Beijing says the camp's
provide vocational training let's go
straight to Beijing for the very latest
on this with DWS Matthias Berliner good
morning Matthias China's calling this
bill a smear but the question is will it
affect the trade talks are very delicate
talks now underway between the US and
China well this spill will not help
easing the trade talks in fact we do not
really know at what stage the trade
talks are we get news every day
different news every day about these
trade talks and we do not see any any
hint that there they are near a closure
of this first phase one trade deal but
what we know is that Beijing has reacted
to another bill that was passed just
recently about Hong Kong and now to this
bill with counter sanctions and it will
not ease this treaty
okay now the intention of course of this
bill is to get China to reconsider
holding hundreds of thousands over a
million Muslim minority leaders in these
camps is there any chance that's going
to happen I don't think it is going to
have many times soon China is sees this
as their internal affair they are
talking about combating terrorism they
are not admitting to human rights
violations that are happening what in
the short term might happen is that they
will enhance their propaganda efforts
they have also threatened to ban
Americans from traveling to the region
but on the long-run pressure on Beijing
is mounting on various issues and
Shenyang is just one of them trade is
another one Hong Kong is another one now
Hong Kong and Xin Jiang these two major
human rights issues international human
rights issues that Beijing is facing
right now might on the long term have an
impact Beijing I think was not expecting
international reaction to be this fierce
mattias thanks very much for that from
Beijing it will be another long day for
Brahm Santosh the week our exile spends
hours in front of his computer poring
over satellite images of his native
shinjang now living in the u.s. he had
to flee the Chinese province to avoid
arrest or worse Baram documents the
destruction of mosques part of an
alleged government effort to eradicate
Muslim religion and weaker culture he
says 10,000 mosques have already been
destroyed demolishing must means no
religion no Islam in the region so this
is a crime this is war against Muslims
it's very important time to
international community who understand
this and do more pressure on China to
save those culture
Beijing regards China's Muslim
population as a security threat its
response to this perceived threat has
been severe over 1 million Muslims are
reportedly in concentration camps
scattered across shinyang most of them
are weekers the government claims these
are vocational training centers but
there's strong evidence that
incarceration in these sites entails
torture rape and brainwashing 11 million
weekers live in chengyang the security
apparatus there combines facial
recognition cameras and sophisticated
surveillance technology with an
oppressive police presence even small
expressions of identity can result in
arrest one of the victims is / roms
father the editor of a weaker newspaper
he was detained and put in a camp his
son has not heard from him since my Papa
could be dying in camp so I had to fight
back if I choose silence and then I
could collect so many in pain in my
heart if I fate fight back I could feel
a little bit better
his father's fate means problems fight
for weaker rights is personal